[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in my guy David Pollock uh
he's such an stud such an awesome
analyst has been for so long the three
time allamerican at Georgia any if
you're a three-time All-American all
that tells me is you didn't go pro early
enough that's all I know David it's Ross
Tucker man really appreciate the time
how are you three-time all America why
didn't you leave school early the year
before uh I could have uh wanted to stay
to win a Natty but it didn't work um we
were weer quite as good as these classes
man that they've had the last several
years but um I was a freshman all americ
too but that doesn't count um but the
cookie debate is amazing I don't eat
cookies ever um but I always was the the
philosophy of the softer cookies you put
in the microwave and you heat them up
and then the harder cookies yes you can
I think you dip in milk but y y'all ever
heat the soft cookies up just to make
them warm yes yeah just okay so let's
talk about that by the way because I
noticed the last couple years on game
day when they would bring food out you
wouldn't eat it so like let's talk so so
what is this about I know you're ripped
and I know you're is it just uh
discipline is it overall health is it
just you want to make sure you have the
six-pack abs like what are we doing here
all of the above I think it's I I eat my
I eat the same food every single day um
and I'm very strict I don't I don't
touch you know fried foods I don't touch
alcohol I don't touch sweets I haven't
in ever um in a I haven't touched sweets
in like 15 years I haven't touched
alcohol um which I thought like twice in
my life but like just very regimented
very strict I want to know what's going
in my body Okay Ross listen we can both
agree on this we've both been fat okay
we' both been large I'm just not trying
to go back anymore and I got to be very
healthy in what I choose because my
metabolism ain't like a lot of peoples
all right so see see this is what
happens on the D Patrick's show I have
like all these college football
questions but now I have to know what
you eat the same thing every day because
by the way I am very similar to you I
eat pretty much the same thing Monday
through Thursday but then I travel so
much on the weekends I'm going to enjoy
the city I'm in like when I was in
Chicago last weekend I got a steak at
Gibson's right like I'm going to enjoy
that and but I have to be disciplined
during the week to be able to do that
and not go back up to 300 so what do you
eat every day well food is fuel to me um
but I do a carton of egg whites o and
oats um that's always my breakfast which
I eat like around 12 or one then I do uh
Greek yogurt and blueberries is always
my next meal and then at night my wife
always makes um some form of like fish
chicken uh steak with vegetables so
that's that's you that's my everyday um
throwing a throwing a protein shake in
the morning a protein shake at night and
that's my everyday lifestyle talking
with the guy David poock who as you can
tell if you're watching on peacock is
absolutely shredded what do you weigh
right now uh 240 yeah he is a yolked 240
speaking of egg whites let's dive into
some of this college stuff you know
what's funny by the way David and you're
the P perfect person to talk to about
this all the talk about the college
football playoff on the four best teams
you know I have a betting podcast and I
was asking the guy do you know that
Georgia would have been favored on a
neutral field against all four of those
teams so the whole notion of Alabama
getting in over Florida State because we
got to do with the four best teams that
was always false that that was never the
truth because it wasn't the four best
teams because I still think Georgia
might be the best team David yeah and
I'm with you but but the the committee's
been very consistent by the way they
don't put in the four best teams they
always put in the four teams that can
justify the the best that's what they've
always done that's what they're always
continued to do um but the cool thing is
Ross in the future we got 12 teams and
we're garanteed to have the four best
when we're picking out of 12 and and
it's going to be decided on the on the
field which will be uh super super cool
but George's man they're just they're so
talented U banged up at the end of the
year played their worst game against
Alabama Alabama uh played really good
Georgia uh you know caught some had a
bad turnover inside their own uh 10
missed a field goal and lost by three
you know and and that was including with
some guys that were dinged up so yeah I
think a healthy Georgia teams was was
the best team in the country but we've
said that a lot about a lot of different
teams and you got to earn your way there
and look at Washington man how freaking
cool is it that Washington who by the
way their last 10 games Ross their last
10 wins they've won under 10 points like
hasn't been dominant hasn't killed
people continued to win continue to get
rewarded and now they're playing for a
dang national title it's unbelievable
and I think that's one of the things
that jumps out to me the most usually I
feel like when you get to the college
football playoff the teams that have
been undefeated it's like they're almost
due for a loss as opposed to like a one
loss b or a one loss Texas but that's
not what happened I me we got the two
undefeated teams and they've both beaten
everybody they faced all year I think it
makes Monday night even better and I
think the fact whether it was Michigan
or Alabama David I really feel like one
way or the other there was a team that
people were going to root against right
so Michigan I don't know if it's the
hard ball thing or the cheating thing or
whatever Alabama it was just people that
thought it should have been Florida
State instead of them so I feel like a
lot of people don't even know that much
about Washington that are GNA be rooting
like heck for Washington Monday night
just because they don't want Michigan to
win oh correct but first of all Ross
Hold up now it ain't just because the
cheating scandal everybody would pull or
Bama it ain't just because everybody be
pulling against Bama regardless like
people aren't pulling for Bama the the
world wants Bama to lose I mean the
cheating scandal pissed people off and
made people cheer against Michigan but
when they played Alabama everybody still
cheered for Michigan because they wanted
Alabama to lose just because they've had
they've been so successful but no
Washington Underdog Story Underdog
quarterback Underdog coach like there
there's nothing better than this and
here's the thing like we talk about a
day and age where it's all about
recruiting it's about getting the five
stars the Blue Chips Washington's best
players are three star kids they're guys
that have been developed that have been
around for a little while now with
pennick being in his second year their
left tackle who's by the way what are
the most important positions in football
Ross we're GNA go quarterback we're g to
go edge rusher we're GNA go offensive
tackle and I'll say nowadays football
you're going to go wide receiver guess
what Washington has by the way the Mr
Underdog they got four guys that'll go
in the first round probably in in one in
each of those spots I mean think about
that like they are really good where it
matters if if Ohio state Alabama don't
have those great quarterbacks when when
they have when the elite teams have the
elite quarterbacks it's over it's a wrap
when they don't teams can get beat and
now you see Alabama they looked really
fallible you see Michigan win but how
about Monday night the contrast of
styles we're going to pitch it all over
the yard we're going to hit you right in
the face if we're Michigan so which
style wins a true blue Bud versus A True
Underdog I think America's definitely
going to be with Washington we're
talking with longtime college football
analyst and former Georgia All-American
David poock you know I haven't heard you
talk about this David or asked you this
how much does the Michigan cheating
thing bother you it bothers me it
bothers me just like the Patriots
Spygate you know like it bothers me
because I think there are lines listen
we know this Ross there's cheating in
every level and it's your job to to
change your signs up and it's your job
to guard against it you know as much as
possible and cover what you can cover
but there's also a line that you can't
cross and there's also a line like when
you start filming different things PE
Patriots cheating like big time cheating
uh when you start doing taking it to
that level I think it becomes it becomes
a different animal and and I think
Michigan definitely took it there and
listen you got one guy that takes the
fall Harbaugh gets suspended to their
credit the way they've handled that has
been amazing and it's been a battlecry
right it's been us against the world and
and they've kept it together and somehow
haven't you know lost Focus but no it's
definitely disturbing it to me it's just
like the Spy gate it's taken too far
there there are there are boundaries and
there are rules that are stret listen
there are people every offseason that
get hired from different schools for
that purpose to get their hand signals
to get their operating procedures to
understand what they do um but to film
different things and to do it to the
extent that they did it to is is
unacceptable you know it's interesting
Monday night David my initial reaction
would have been that I think Michigan's
just too good up front and can beat up
Washington up front I don't think that's
the case Washington's better up front
than I realize watching them against
Texas yeah I mean they they got a again
an offens a left tackle that's goingon
to be drafted in the first round an edge
rusher that leads the nation the last
two years in pressures so that they've
got some guys man they they play
physical they play tough they play hard
they play Sound Washington dealt with a
little bit of injuries at safety they
were on their like fifth safety at one
point they've gotten healthier in the
back end they've got a really good
Corner in Prince like a really good
corner so it's a it's a good it's a good
defense it's not a great defense U
Michigan's pass rush was insane versus
Alabama um if they rush the passer like
that and they can get pressure on
pennick that's the way you can
absolutely beat him I'll be interested
to see how how Washington Texas had a
lot of success running the football Ross
like I think Michigan obviously is set
set up more to do that I love the way
Michigan finished that game against
Alabama like when it was nut cutting
time and it was time to like to win the
football game Run Run touchdown like and
they played physical smacks mouth so I
think it is contrasting Styles the key
to me will be pennick Jr and it will be
his ability to do what he did against
Texas when your offensive line gets beat
specifically in the interior and they
get beat can you make a guy Miss and
deliver a strike because he did man like
he can consistently would he's not a
freak athlete but he's got enough of
that shake to step up and throw it and
when he throws it you just that thing
comes out hot and it comes out right
down the field 20 plus yards down the
field he's the best in the country and
it just drops in a bucket consistently
just it's unbelievable so it'll be
contrasting styles for sure yeah I'm
curious just your thoughts on sort of
the state of college football right now
it's interesting because with all the
transfer portal stuff and the ni stuff
and then you have all these bowl games
where we don't know who's playing who's
not but then I was looking at the
ratings for the bowl games it doesn't
seem to matter it it it really doesn't
matter it's like which by the way is a
whole other conversation people really
are just rooting for the uniforms right
like it doesn't matter necessarily who's
in those uniforms has it taken away your
love of the sport because I know you
love college football has all the portal
nil stuff hurt your affinity for the
sport or not at all not at all um I'll
be honest though Ross when it started
happening you're like dude what the heck
is going on like this is strange this is
weird um but man the college football is
just the pageantry and every Saturday
and just the traditions and and listen
I'm from the south right so like this is
not like a a a fandom thing that's one
generation this is like generation upon
generation upon Generations like
grandpas going to games with their grand
Grands son and and their son like it's a
family affair man like it just it runs
so much deeper and you could take D3
guys and get rid of all D1 guys and you
could put them in those D1 uniforms and
and all those guys could go away and
everybody would still cheer for their
squad they would still cheer for their
team like there's just something about
and listen I'll be honest you know I got
canned this year so being the first year
being on the couch like it was fantastic
to have a Saturday like to watch to just
sit there and watch it all like to see
it to see the different uh the different
games and just to follow it it was cool
man just to be a fan and um listen
college football is is healthy because
all the the generations of people that
I'm an Ohio State fan like I'm a Georgia
fan I'm a Clemson fan my granddaddy
heads tickets I go the stadiums are
packed the atmospheres are crazy um does
it Le more craziness and our coaches
losing sleep because because because
NCAA has done a horrible job of
legislating the nil and legislating the
transfer portal yes does it lead does it
give some people headaches and does it
tick them off yes are they still going
to wear their colors and watch their
team on Saturday Absol freaking lutely
you know if if anything it's weird
because just seeing certain kids even
going to the transfer portal this week
it's almost has like an NBA effect where
it's like creates this off seon of
excitement and people it's it keeps
college football almost in the news more
often if that makes sense it's it's
really strange appreciate the time man
always good to see you I mean every once
in a while dude just a little ice cream
like a little bit of ice cream never hey
here's the thing Ross know thyself your
boy is not a one bite kind of guy okay
if one bite goes down 12 bytes 20 bites
30 btes are going down don't need it bro
great to talk with you man than thanks
so much for coming on the show see
brother by the way I I